dermatologue de la génération katfoe nous faisons un
vlog pour consoie
la chanson de Liu Yan lors d'un goûter à ya
quelqu'un Xue ers apparemment effrayant
equesticle q Daniel ce sera toi tais-
toi sur enregistrer pour sauver une heureuse
attaque de trésorerie EV en vente May Louie Armstrong vadia
a  Lotus était Camilla camarade privé Oh
Deborah deuxième dit illa solvet public
était accent quand il fait l'heure de dormir dans le
sud
que les votes sont Bruning shop seul tu
ne m'as pas dit pourquoi parce que je sais quand un
temps de sommeil si mauvais que cela
signifie que faire  sale subtil qui condamne la
façon étrange des médecins sont bonsoir
tout le monde
regarde était la partie arrière Louie Armstrong
Satchmo hospice on cycle l'autre autre
musique à cadix 'j'aimerais pouvoir
me suivre c'est moi qui deviens jeune madame vous devez
avoir en retour à moi  vous rend heureux et
jeune pastillage aqnd jazz madame qu'est-ce que
les chaises modernes livrez-les dites-moi je
ne sais pas j'essaie juste de jouer de la bonne musique
je m'en fous mais je veux dire si je vais acheter un
disque ne vois pas un peu les paniers  Jazz
Medel  merc national c'est ce que j'ai donc il
peut pas vendre une musique mojo nostalgique mais
tu jet donc j'aime la musique et le
son tu me manques je suis quelques bureaux sur le
tennis tu dis jamais Boop j'appuie sur le
raté tu musique jazz viens ici  Fella
Oh la musique est de la musique jazz chaque morceau
explique en jazz si vous voulez regarder de
cette façon c'était commercial et les
musiciens de jazz tendaient dans des
pots de vitalité totalement musicaux serveur nommé Lilu venez vous-même
au vignoble sur Charles j'aime mon bébé
mais je sais tout  était populaire une
fois ou une autre a dit que la courbe de bonus était
limitée adulte c'est une question de
publicité c'est ce que vous mettez dans une mélodie
ici pas de publicité appelée airs ou jazz
Babbitt octopod désobéir aux bulles vous gagnez
ces saules
c'est l'amour douce mélodie et tout ça
vœux avec un bébé oui tu fais partie de moi
toujours total mardi boppity-bop se
battre dans le dos quand tu te sens
déprimé tu sais que c'est bien j'arrive à chéri
tu ne peux pas le faire sauter encore en train de sonder tu
arrêterais toujours les favoris
chéri un ph  jeu d'otographe
balancer et défendre en jouant l'une de nos
blagues préférées
n'est-ce pas